a little thing called the houston texans
trying to reverse a
pretty clear perception slash reality of
dysfunction naming a new head coach
today and then making him available
to reporters it was david culley the new
coach nick casario the new gm let's hear
from both of them
as it relates to the most important
questions surrounding not just the
texans but the entire national football
league
what is the status of quarterback
deshaun watson here they are
the only thing i knew about this whole
situation at that point was is that i
was being interviewed for for this job
to be the head coach
and i did know at that point deshawn
watson is a houston texan he's a
quarterback of the houston texans and
that's all that i was concerned about
and that's all i knew and and whatever
was been said about what was been what
he wanted to do or he didn't want to do
all i know is this having been in this
business this long you know he is a
houston texan and
i want him to be a houston texan and the
reason i'm in this position today is
because i knew he's going to be a
houston texan organizationally
just want to reiterate our commitment to
desean watson
he's had a great impact on this
organization a great impact on a lot of
people great impact on this team
and we look forward the opportunity to
spend more time with them here this
spring once we get started and you know
we have zero interest in trading the
player um we have a great plan a great
vision for for him and for this team and
his role in our team and we look forward
to the opportunity to spend more time
with him here this spring
that was nick casaro before that david
culley now shireen williams joining us
i'm sure shereen you either heard just
now or heard earlier today the things
that kelly and cassario had to say about
deshaun watson what was your first
reaction when you hear the words you see
the delivery and you get a chance to
really think through the message they're
sending
i think they want to keep
uh deshawn juan
watson but i don't know if that's going
to be possible mike he has made it clear
that he wants out
now how they work that out i don't know
how what how that evolves i don't know
but this is
gonna kill the houston texans mike
yeah you know i agree with you and i was
studying every aspect of the press
conference today for some sort of a clue
some sort of a sign are they planning to
draw a hard line or are they just saying
what they have to say
like rick spielman the vikings gm eight
years ago when percy harvin was rumored
to be available in trade the catchphrase
from spielman and i still remind him of
it all the time
we have no intent to trade percy harvin
percy harvin was traded a couple of days
after he made that statement zero
interest in trading deshaun watson to me
means nothing when it's snowing out and
it's garbage night and it's time to take
the bags out to the cans that are
through six inches of snow i have no
interest in doing it but i do it so i
heard nothing and not just from that
comment i heard nothing that causes me
to think they are taking a hard-line
position a couple of additional snippets
from casario that i think are relevant
let's begin with
his comment after john mcclane of the
houston chronicle asked caserio what
they intend to do to try to salvage the
relationship with watson here's caserio
the best way that you handle
relationships is to communicate and be
honest and be forthright and we're going
to do that with everybody that's in this
building from equipment to training
staff to coaching staff to personnel to
players
yeah look you have to establish a line
of communication before you can have the
communication sharing the problem is if
he won't talk to nick casario if he
won't talk to david culley if he won't
talk to cal mcnair how do you change his
mind if his mind's made up and he's
built a wall and he's taking your number
out of his phone if he's left the chat
if he's gone if he's over you can't
communicate with him he talked about
getting him in there in the spring well
95 of the off-season program if they
even have one this year is voluntary he
doesn't have to show up so
they've got a lot of work to do before
they even get to have the conversation
it's too late to have the conversation
you can't salvage without the
conversation
mike you talked about if your boss calls
you answer the phone even if you're on
vacation and he didn't do that and he's
obviously not answering their calls now
so
you know it's now up to nick casario and
david culley to clean up the mess that
was created by cal mcnair and jack
easterby
and
they've got to try to do that and i
don't think they have a chance to do
that because of the mess that easter bee
and mcnair made of this and it's a huge
mess and it's unfortunate for the
houston texans and their fans
houston texans fans deserve better
this team deserves better this
organization does not deserve better and
they don't deserve desean watson and
he's not answering his phone mike if i'm
david culley i leave a message which i'm
sure he's already done now
and then i get lamar jackson to call him
and then i get other players that desean
watson would
play under me tyree kill whoever it is
to call deshaun watson and i would keep
having those players call various
players i don't know if that's going to
work i don't think it is i think once
you ask for a trade as you said
repeatedly mike the bridge has been
burned down there's no turning back at
this point
and david culley's comments on the
situation were a little bit confusing he
said i'm in this position because i know
deshaun watson's going to be here that's
just a guess that's not information from
deshaun watson there was no suggestion
that any of those guys have spoken with
desean watson and gotten any sort of
commitment there was nothing to push
back against the accepted narrative that
he wants out it's a given that he wants
out the question is how do they turn it
around another comment from caserio that
caught my attention and we'll listen to
it right here caserio was asked by
another reporter about the timeline
for figuring this out with deshaun
watson let's listen to what casario had
to say
there's going to be some player
decisions that we're going to have to
make so i think right now we're just
going to take it one day at a time focus
on what we can control and what we can
handle um today the day is about david
and you know once we get through here
today with david the next thing we'll
turn to is staff construction and you
know we're gonna spend as much time as
possible on that and and what the vision
is for the team and what the staff has
in mind as well so we're just gonna take
it one day at a time and just try to
make good decisions one day at a time
and you know do what we think is best
for the organization
sharing that was the moment where i
concluded they are going to trade him
and that the door is open to trade him
and that anyone out there who's
interested in trading for him should
start submitting offers unsolicited to
the houston texans and eventually
someone will make them an offer they
won't and can't refuse because if you
ask nick casario
what's the timeline for making a
decision
the answer
if the decision is we're not trading him
is there is no timeline we're not
trading him there's no timeline he's a
member of this team he can play with us
or he can play for no one he has a
contract that covers the next four years
he is our quarterback we want him to be
here and we will wait for him as long as
it takes and if he chooses to exercise
his rights under the cba to stay away
from the offseason program the mandatory
mini camp training camp pre-season
regular season that's his right but
we're not going anywhere because we want
him on this team and we're here to tell
our fans that he is a member of this
team and he's not going anywhere and if
you say anything other than that
you're telling the rest of the league in
not as many words
make us an offer and eventually we won't
refuse it
yeah i i do think the door is open if
they get an offer they can't refuse mike
and i'm expecting them to get an offer
they can't refuse and i'm
expecting a lot of teams to get in on
the bidding and call and say hey even if
you're not listening
you know here's what we're offering if
you are listening if you ever are
listening and they do have a little bit
of time here and if they keep saying
we're not trading them maybe that helps
the value go up in this thing mike and
maybe they figure out that they're not
going to be able to work things out with
deshaun watson when he doesn't answer
their phone calls and doesn't respond in
repeatedly
says i want to be traded through his
agent at some point something has to
give mike but you know this organization
has not earned
any credibility at this point i think
with what they've done
uh in recent years not just months but
years and i have no faith that they're
going to have this play out in their
favor i mean i know it's a different gm
i get it's a different regime
but the texans have been the texans for
so long that you just don't think that
they're going to do this the right way
that they're going to do the best for
the organization i mean we've seen it so
many times you go back to genevion
clowney even back to dwayne brown to
deandre hopkins to laramie tunnel all
the trades they have made mike they came
out on the losing end of those trades
whether they were giving away players or
getting players they gave up too much
for but you look at geneva and clowning
mike they waited so long to trade him
that they didn't get what he was worth
and i could see the same scenario
playing out for the texas
and they had to pay roughly seven
million dollars of jadavian county
salary to get the deal done that got
them a mid-round pick and a couple of
players in return and you know there are
some questions and concerns that
football fans raise as it relates to
this entire situation and
one of the questions is
why in the world would the texans even
consider doing this how does it get to
that point that they would consider it
they should never even consider it the
problem is they've let it get to the
point right where the guy wants out the
damage is already done they've already
screwed up whatever it is that they were
able to screw up to get their franchise
quarterback just what six months not
even that
after signing this long-term contract
he's decided i want out that's on the
team for failing to have the right
relationship the right atmosphere the
right everything that makes your
franchise quarterback want to be there
for the entirety of his career and he's
privy to things from being on the inside
that we're not we've picked up some of
it through the excellent reporting of
folks like jenny ventus and greg bishop
of si.com but i assume watson knows even
more about how
nuts it's gotten for lack of a better
term within the texans organization and
it's driven him to the point where he
wants out that's on the texans for
having a dysfunctional shop that's not
on the person who's reacting to the
function dysfunction by saying i got to
get the hell out of here
the only thing i would say mike is it's
on deshaun watson for signing that
contract in in september and i know it
was a 156
million dollars but he knew they'd
already traded deandre hopkins he knew
they didn't have a very good roster and
he knew that bill o'brien was still the
head coach in the gm and jack easterby
was there and all those things were in
place so i'm surprised that he signed
the extension and now it has him in this
position looking to be traded when he
does have a no trade clause obviously
and can dictate sort of where he goes
kind of sort of so you know they're both
in this mess for reasons and you know i
don't know how it how it works out in
the end but it's going to be fascinating
to watch for however long it plays out
it's going to be the top storyline we're
going to be talking about this every
single day mike and i absolutely love it
one other thing about the contract
because you make a great point and it
dovetails with other questions that i
get from people he signed a contract he
has a contract all he had to do was say
i don't want the extension well at the
time maybe he hadn't come to the
conclusion that i need to get the hell
out of this place that has become a
dysfunctional hell hole secondly you
don't say no to generational wealth you
clean up the mess on the back end once
you acquire the generational wealth and
the reward for what you've already done
the current labor deal doesn't give the
players the reward on the way in it
gives them the reward after they've put
in a few years in deshaun watson's mind
it's fair to conclude i got paid for
what i've done not necessarily for what
i'm going to do and finally let's
remember because there's always going to
be an old school football guy that goes
on tv or on radio and says he signed a
contract he needs to honor it there are
two contracts that apply to every player
in the national football league one the
contract between him and his team
to the contract between all players and
all teams known as the collective
bargaining agreement and it gives
players clear rights to withhold
services if they're willing to pay a
fifty thousand dollar per day fine for
skipping training camp if they're
willing to pay back signing bonus money
they haven't earned yet if they retire
if they sit out a full season they're
not forced to work they have rights and
even if they're technically violating
the terms of their individual contract
they're fully within their rights
shireen under the broader contract and
this is a great reminder of that dynamic
because
yes
technically
he's not honoring his contract but
technically he is because his contract
is backed up by the cba
and my modern era players are so
empowered now i mean we've seen it and
when you start
i'm sure we're going to talk later about
jimmy johnson and what he said that he
wouldn't trade deshaun watson no matter
what they
offered even if it was herschel walker
like trade compensation but let's go
back to that time there was no free
agency players weren't empowered it was
different there was no salary cap things
were different than than they are now
and power players do have power and they
can dictate
things about their even if they have a
contract where they want to go they can
hold up there's all sorts of things they
can do that they couldn't do in the past
that is it now and deshaun watson is is
absolutely exercising uh that right and
and i have a feeling if the texas don't
trade him i don't think we're gonna see
him and i don't think we're gonna see
him for a while maybe it's like dwayne
brown maybe he holds out into the season
until they they finally say okay he's
really not coming back
and it's better to not see him than to
have him show up and be the equivalent
of jaylen ramsey where he's not
practicing because of an injury that
otherwise he would practice with if he
was happy about his circumstance right
the injury if he's not showing up early
staying late studying the playbook
influencing and leading the team now i
don't think he's wired that way
but if i'm the texans i don't want to
push that i don't want to find out i'd
rather just pull the plug on it and
realize that my best interests are to do
a deal before the draft ideally before
the start of free agency on march 17
because if you wait until after that to
work out terms teams that may have been
interested may make other plans you want
to get this done if you're the texans
you want to maximize value you want to
get it done before march 17 and then you
want to formalize it when the new league
year begins at 401 pm eastern
that should be the objective by the
houston texans whether or not they're
smart enough to figure that out remains
to be seen because they're not smart
enough as
recent history has shown us to make
their franchise quarterback happy and
otherwise make good decisions about how
the team is going to be operated all
right they are hiring lovey smith to be
the defensive coordinator he's been out
of the nfl for five years he was
jettisoned by the tampa bay buccaneers
in
what
and you know what dirk cutter's retired
now so i can say it people thought it
was a palace coup people thought it was
an inside job much like it was when john
gruden was fired for raheem morris the
thinking was they fired lovey smith for
dirk cutter because dirk cutter was
drawing interest elsewhere and he was
the guy who was supposed to get the most
out of jameis winston now after five
years
at that i haven't followed college
football that closely over the past five
years but i get the impression he wasn't
very good as the head coach at illinois
now he gets to be the defensive
coordinator shireen at the houston
texans
and it's a good move frankly for david
culley to surround himself with guys who
have been head coaches previously
because he has no head coaching
experience and as everyone's pointed out
he has no coordinator experience so he
needs a veteran guy and lovey is
certainly that they they didn't overlap
and tampa lovey came in after david
culley left tampa
but i do think they have they know
they've gone way back and know each
other i don't think they've ever worked
together before but they do know each
other so i think this is a good pick up
for the texas i think he's added some
really good coaches but the facts are
they don't have very many good players
and that's what you win with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports